moi c'est non parce que tu peux pas
comment tu vas jauger tuer ou le barème
le mec il vient il vient tu sais même
pas si c'est un cambrioleur ça se trouve
ça ça se bat avec ses facturations mais
tu vas les dents tu vas aller dans un
temps brouillé avec incarne le mec qui
va tirer dessus à dire je croyais qu'il
voulait me tirer dessus fnbs qu'ils
aient au mas doit quel est pour
vous pas s'il réduit on s'en fout pas
dans ce qu'on s'en fout tu m'as la
question à quoi tu me parles de quelques
acteurs en martinique
[Applaudissements]
mais c'était vous étiez pas hyper
intéressant
mais quelle que soit la raison pour
laquelle mais de manière assez content
en gros en france là là là il faut que
l'attaqué etc 3 proportionnelle avec la
défense soient proportionnels attaque ça
veut dire que si on s'attaque dans la
rue avec un couteau et que tu te défends
avec un revolver tu vas être condamné
c'est ça la
défense à l'attaqué et c'est par les
dragons mieux c'est ce qui n'arrive pas
aux états unis dont est victime ce qu'il
est en train de dire aujourd'hui c'est
que la personne maintenant qui va
rentrer chez toi que ce soit avec un
couteau que tu es un couteau suisse que
tu veux ou une arme à part turmoil
rentre chez toi et qu'elle passe ta
propriété tu pourras te défendre tous
avec l'âme que tu veux mais tu échoues
que ces
ménages comme tu te rends compte
[Rires]
à dix secondes ouverte qu'au
jeu des bars ovomaltine
mais là non mais non mais non c'est moi
qui donne la parole ici dans mon frère
tp people ça sera le bordel ici c'était
pmp tu viens avec ce que vous voulez ce
que vous voulez mathieu c'est le droit
de vengeance
mais si vous avez dit oui pas toujours
bien compris c'est le far west ce que
vous voulez on a déjà tout dans
l'arsenal législatif en plus les juges
aujourd'hui ils tiennent compte des
circonstances atténuantes c'est à dire
que la peine diminue quand on jusque là
situation a fait que vous avez
changé vous voulez alors
voulez vous que font les suisses c'est
un maire avec sursis ça de la prochaine
fois ils veulent ranger sur cinq ans il
avait compris donc les suisses ils
tiennent compte de l'émotion boulet
qu'on tienne compte de l'émotion c'est à
dire que j'ai été attaqué j'étais mûr
c'est sa scierie pascual avant gens ont
parlé de couteau sistino mais c'est la
suite zemmour veut s'inspirer de la
suisse le mail on parlait de couteau
suisse
simona parler de reparler de couteau
suisse érige explique je suis vierge il
alors oui ou alors vas-y zemmour et il
veut faire quelque chose qui existe en
suisse effectivement à wilkow en suisse
par exemple s'ils laissent la riposte
n'est pas proportionnée la possibilité
de réduire votre peine c'est de dire je
ne mangeais cru que et on explique pour
quelles raisons comme vous comme votre
bijoutier qui a cru que le petit footing
on
aurait pu se retourner et le tuer et
c'est pour ça qu'il n'a eu que du sursis
et pas la peine de rentrer elles n'ont
pour ça et donc en france on a sept
arsenault qui permet à la fois d'avoir
et la légitime défendons et c'est la
légitime défense ne taxerait pas les
circonstances atténuantes nationale
c'est enfin et aux gens qui s'attaquent
aujourd'hui et bien peuvent s'en prendre
non ça c'est l'eau devrait s'élever
remis deux
autres s'ils vous dégagez vous parlez
sont les autres
donc tu dégages animateurs
[Rires]
les défoncer alors est ce la terre
défoncée
on s'est fait attaquer font ça cette
annonce est un peu sexy un peu
bling-bling parce que en gros il dit il
faut faire peur ou voyou il faut que la
peur change de camp de hockey mais sauf
que en pratique c'est n'importe quoi
c'est de la poudre aux yeux comment tu
vas faire chez toi tu vas voir un
couteau suisse un coup d'arrêt un
revolver de quiron tu m'étonnes
jacoulot pizza mais c'est vrai que cette
d'une veille dans la rue comment tu
réagis néo quoi on en train d'expliquer
la défense et ses proportions de
l'etivaz quoi je vais tirer dans l'est
mais on attend la conventionnelle je ne
sais pas c'est pas c'est pas notre rôle
en asie citoyens de faire là mais c'est
quoi oui c'est quoi ton rôle qu'elle
garde chez toi fais d'abord la police
mais arrivés huit minutes après qu'est
ce que tu fais ma chérie et ben je
préfère déjà que cela n'arrive pas mieux
sinon j'appelle à pleyben ça n'arrivera
pas toi les gens ont pas de rentrer chez
le docteur c'est dissuader les composés
le port d'armes alors oui les armureries
en tous les cas que les jambes il faut
bien gens qui rentre chez toi ce qu'ils
ont à danger non mais c'est régis
maccarone chez vous bah oui oui vous
comment vous faites quoi
mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
avec un flingue mais sans déconner
quelques jours c'est énorme c'est
pas parce que moi j'ai été cambriolé
voilà et ceux qui m'ont cambrioler
contre prix ont pris les clés de chez
moi en partant les effets des crises ont
pris un double sens ils sont partis chez
moi d'accord ils ont pas exempt de tout
prendre la police vient est prêt jeddah
et jeudi mais j'étais un peu en panique
s'ils reviennent puisqu'ils ont les clés
gs que j'ai droit est armé à bord une
bombe lacrymogène a pris le relais tous
bien
alors j s'ils reviennent qu'est ce que
je fais dit vous nous appelez bas mais
cette belle jambe ne rien voir trois
roumains qui sont chez moi
ce sous pardon que c'était un gang de
l'ess qui s'occupait alors été arrêtés
pouvaient pas stigmatiser
sa mâture il n'ya pas dire ça dans ma
rue et surtout que dans mes alors été
arrêté c'était un homme des genres et
alors rien ne peut pas dire comme ça dit
non mais ça ce n'est pas alors c'est
qu'il n'en attendez attendez mon mari
c'était ça que je te dise j'ai parlé ont
déchiré un peu de respect dans ça je
supporte pas un homme je vous le dis
donc tu te retires sa personne qui sont
très costaud en face de toi oui
qu'est ce que tu fais tu fais une pause
d où la rue pour un téléphone tu fais le
17 et u les attends tu les regardes ben
voilà c'est ça ce que proposent les lois
de gilles cinéma m'a fait rire ça
m'étonne que la fonte des glaces les
faux dans la nuit mais ses commandes à
4h du mat tu changes la serrure il ya
des iphone se rendre au tibet ou
je ne dis pas question
il ya des cycles
alessia l'année si ça ne coûte pas 15
mai c'est d'ailleurs ce
constat